hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american psychological
thriller film called fractured
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
raymond rowe with his wife joanne and
his daughter perry
is driving home from his in-laws house
it is the day of thanksgiving
the couple argues about their
relationship as perry sits in the back
seat listening to music on her
headphones
joanne begins to cry knowing that their
marriage is at its ending
as they argue perry's headphones stop
working so the couple stops arguing and
sings songs with perry to keep her
entertained
sometime later perry has to go to the
bathroom
ray pulls over at a gas station joanne
takes perry to the washroom
as ray goes to buy batteries for perry's
headphones coffee and a coke for joanne
however he is short on money so he
ditches the batteries and gets two
liquor bottles for himself
back in the car he lies to joanne
telling her that the store did not have
batteries
ray is about to start the car when perry
notices that her compact is missing
when they do not find it in the car
joanne goes to look for it in the
washroom
ray gets up to check under perry's seat
but accidentally drops his coffee
perry is outside the car as rey is
distracted
kerry wanders off to a nearby
construction site she sees a balloon and
goes near it
just then a dog comes near her she
starts calling ray for help
as perry retreats she is stuck between
the dog and a construction pit
ray finally notices the dog and asks
perry not to move and slowly tries to
advert the dog's direction towards
himself
just as ray throws a stone at it perry
gets scared and falls into the pit
ray runs to save her and falls into the
pit as well he falls unconscious
he wakes up a few seconds later and sees
joanne running towards them
perry lies unconscious beside him while
joanne checks her for injuries
ray is still in shock and doesn't say
anything joanne comes to him crying
hysterically
but he pushes her aside ray closes his
eyes and when he opens it everything
seems normal
perry opens her eyes and he takes a sigh
of relief
however her arm seems to be fractured so
ray gently picks perry and takes her to
the car
joanne suggests they call an ambulance
but ray claims to see a hospital nearby
while they drive to the hospital ray
nearly crashes into another car
perry lies in the back seat with joanne
and is in a lot of pain
when the family gets to the hospital
joanne and perry sit in the waiting area
as ray checks them in
the hospital is crowded so the
receptionist tells him to wait for their
turn
as the three of them wait perry whimpers
in pain ray goes to the receptionist
again and asks to be sent earlier than
others
however she just makes him sign
paperwork and asks him to wait
he goes back to his family in the
waiting area where joanne apologizes to
him for being rude earlier
after a while the nurse calls ray's name
the family is taken to a room
where the nurse notes down required
information about them
the questions start to get intrusive
which annoys the couple
the nurse then asks them to register
perry as an organ donor but they refuse
even after being denied the nurse pushes
the topic but rey dismisses her
another nurse then takes them to a ward
perry is put into a hospital bed
and a doctor finally sees her he
confirms that perry's arm is broken and
tells them that she needs a cast
when the doctor finds out that perry has
also hit her head he advises them to do
a ct scan
the nurses cast perry's arm she is then
put in a wheelchair and taken to the ct
scan lab
it turns out that only one parent can go
to the area at once
so ray stays outside perry tells him
that she loves him before they part
ray falls asleep while waiting for them
he wakes up in a few hours
and asks the receptionist about his
family but since the shifts have changed
she doesn't know anything she asks him
to wait while she checks the records
it has been several minutes but the
receptionist doesn't say anything
ray asks her again this time a little
annoyed
she then checks the morning record but
perry's name is not in it
frustrated ray asks to see the doctor
who checked perry
but he has changed shifts too agitated
rey yells at the receptionist and bangs
her desk
so she immediately calls the ct room
however
the person from the lab tells her that
only one old woman has come to the lab
that day
ray is beyond frustrated he angrily asks
her about his family
but the receptionist looks at him as if
he is crazy she even blames him for
coming into the wrong hospital
ray insists that it is not possible but
she ignores him and starts talking to
someone else
worried about his family ray runs to the
restricted area of
the hospital only to be stopped by the
officials there
he informs them of their visit this
morning the doctor checks the day's
record but sees no patient by the name
of monroe
frustrated ray looks around and sees the
nurse who helped them earlier
the nurse recognizes rey believing that
he has proved his point
rey sighs in relief but the nurse adds
that she doesn't know anything about his
daughter or his wife
according to her ray came in for a head
injury and was alone
agitated ray blames the nurse for lying
the doctor assumes he has a contusion
from his head injury and offers to treat
him
however ray almost attacks the nurse and
has to be restrained
the doctor injects him with sedatives to
calm him down
he is then locked into a room by the
guards ray tries to unlock the door
but the drugs make him hazy to make the
sedative not work he injects himself
with an injection he finds in the
cabinets
he then tries to unlock the door again
but it doesn't work
hence he breaks the glass door and runs
out of the room
however before he can escape people
notice him running away
the security chases him but ray somehow
manages to run out of the hospital and
hide in his car
a police car is right outside the
hospital too taking the opportunity
ray stops the car and tells the police
about joanne and perry
the police suspecting that he is lying
ask for identification
after he shows them his id they agree to
help him
the receptionist sees ray walk into the
hospital again but this time
she cannot do anything because of the
police officers she calls the security
before assisting them
the guards then let them in ray takes
the police to the doctor from earlier
the doctor admits that there can be a
mistake in the records and ray demands
they'd be taken to the ct lab
the doctor agrees however the guards
take them to the third floor
ray clearly remembers the ct lab being
in the basement
at the lab it is clear that perry was
never there
ray then demands to call dr berthram who
had checked perry that morning
the staff obliges just then the
receptionist comes in with the paper
that ray had signed this morning
however it doesn't prove the presence of
joanne and perry
dr birthroom finally arrives and reveals
that ray came to the hospital alone to
get treated for his head injury
the doctor had asked him to do a ct scan
but he refused
saying that his wife abby was waiting
for him outside the police officers get
suspicious of rey because he has told
them that his wife's name is joanne
not abby ray then reveals that abby is
his ex-wife
who has been dead for years helpless ray
accuses the hospital of kidnapping his
family
the security guard suggests they look at
the cctv camera footage to see if rey is
lying
the group then watches the footage for
the morning but perry and joanne are in
none of them
ray claims that it is because of the
camera's angle the police officers do
not believe rey's story anymore
ray then asked them to go to the gas
station to figure the truth
he even finds perry scarf near the
hospital bed she was in the morning
he claims that this proves she was here
but the police need more evidence than
that
the doctor suspect that rey is not in a
mentally stable condition
so they introduce him to a psychiatrist
named teresa jacobs
teresa takes ray to a room and shows him
his administration record
which doesn't mention perry or joanne
teresa calmly talks to him and inquires
about the incidents of that morning
she also asks him about abby ray then
reveals that abby died eight years ago
in a car accident and he couldn't save
her because he was drunk
frustrated he starts to cry teresa now
knows for sure that something is wrong
she suggests the police go look at the
place the accident occurred this morning
according to teresa joanne and perry
might still be there
the police officers then take ray and
teresa to the construction site again
they call for backup to help them with
the search then they find perry's
compact on the pit
they also see a pool of dried blood in
the concrete the police realize that
this cannot be raised blood
because his injury isn't that bad the
missing people and the blood make the
officers realize that the place is a
crime scene
however ray in turn blames the police
officers for planning the compact and
the blood to falsely accuse rey
he believes that the police want to save
the hospital for what they have done to
joanne and perry
teresa on the other hand tries to calm
ray down and asks him what happened to
perry
ray starts to blabber teresa then asks
him if he pushed perry down the pit
this makes rey go silent he doesn't move
and stares into the distance
the police then arrest him on the
suspicion of killing his wife and his
daughter
as they are about to handcuff him ray
snaps he snatches the officer's gun and
points at a teresa
then he makes them go into the gas
station and locks them there
taking teresa's key card ray drives to
the hospital in a police car
he hides the gun and goes inside his
plan is to go to the basement where he
believes that joanne and perry are
captured
while he is at it he comes across the
maternity room
the children remind him of the day abby
died he reminisces of the death which
had killed both abby and his unborn kid
he somehow manages to get a doctor's
apron and disguises himself as one
he gets into the elevator and is about
to go to the basement but the security
guard from earlier joins him
he and ray get into a fight in the end
ray strangles the guard to death and
takes his keys
ray is finally in the basement of the
hospital as he looks around
he finds perry's toy in a bin nearby
sure that his daughter is somewhere near
he takes the gun in his hand and
searches for her then he sees two
doctors delivering boxes of human organ
somewhere
ray finally realizes that joanne and
perry were brought here to get their
organs harvested
this explains the nurse trying to make
perry an organ donor that morning
reed then enters a room and is horrified
to see several dead bodies with missing
organs
he rushes out of the room looking for
perry and finally finds her in another
room being operated on by surgeons
joanne is in the corner of the room
highly sedated
the doctors had drugged her ray then
holds the surgeons at gunpoint
and places both joanne and perry in a
wheelchair but before he can run away
the doctors restrain him they are about
to inject him with drugs
but ray manages to free himself by
shooting a device and causing an
explosion
ray finally runs out of the room with
both joanne and perry in the wheelchair
he kills another doctor in the hallway
he brings his family out of the hospital
and puts them in the back seat of his
car
the family finally drives away to their
home perry tells them that her arm still
hurts
so rey sings her a song to make her feel
better just then
the camera pans to the back seat and we
see that the people sitting there are
two random people that rey is kidnapped
from the middle of their surgery
ray gets flashbacks from the morning and
we get to know that perry died when she
fell into the pit
when ray pushed joanne he killed her as
well rey's mind couldn't handle the pain
of him being the reason for his family's
death
hence his mind constructs a new reality
in which both his wife and daughter are
still alive
ray believes he is rescuing them but it
is revealed that he has kidnapped a
random patient from surgery
joanne and perry's dead bodies were
inside the trunk of his car the whole
time
the movie ends as rey hallucinates
joanne telling him to take them home
and that's the heartbreaking ending of
the movie subscribe for more videos like
this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching